Sri Lankans living in Britain say it
used to be easy to get a visa to come
here and stay but not anymore at this
South London temple many of the
worshipers are struggling with asylum
issues but we've discovered a growing
number have something else in common
according to community leaders the vast
majority of new arrivals are now getting
into the country on fake passports I
would probably say 80 to 85 percent come
in fake passport of people arriving in
Britain right now yeah because they are
really scared they just want to escape
and the new arrivals hope breaks it can
offer job opportunities currently filled
by Europeans
Errol Seeley 3 Thorin does odd jobs at
the temple as she's unable to work and
speaks no English she came on a fake
passport six months ago okay you Kalia
could to go deeper longer she told her
she had to leave Sri Lanka because her
Tamil fiancee was wanted by the
authorities she says there are many more
like her trying to reach Britain on fake
documents so my contacts in the Sri
Lankan community have told me about a
group of men who all came to the UK on
fake passports they are working
illegally doing mechanical work and they
are trying to make ends meet by doing
cash in hand jobs say they are out of
sight of the authorities the group are
fixing cars behind a friend's garage in
London who mirage has been here the
longest and arranges the work for the
others who arrived last summer how much
money do you make fixing cars some
people give me the good morning some
people north I think
how much do you make a week very kind of
bomb
across Britain there's a whole layer of
society trying to survive whilst living
illegally like fav Raja and Kali also
from Sri Lanka they live in a single
room with their two children
everything's here cooking sleeping
studying playing everything here it's
very very hard for me in kids also asked
me when they got home when they go to
proper bed when they got a proper food
they when they asked me a food it's very
hard for it as a mother it's very hard
the whole family sleeps on an old door
covered with blankets the children sign
ash and sir Jana were both born in
Britain and can't understand why their
lives are so different to their school
friends who they are ashamed to invite
round they talk about their friend's
home Transco friend's life style and her
lifestyle so I said we have to wait they
asked me how long how long one of the
day my friend my son asked me Mommy my
friend want to come my home my home
I said no sir Raja has been in Britain
for nearly 20 years
both he and Callie have had their asylum
applications refused but use expired
home office documents to access health
care they say they want to be able to
work and pay taxes do you think brexit
is going to provide opportunities for
you yes it's putting one thing why
I can't go back I can't over everything
after that Dec you think it'll mean is
going to be more work for you yes there
are hundreds even thousands of new
arrivals in the past year from this one
community alone
coming into Britain on fake passports
there's no evidence to suggest brexit
will change the status of those living
illegally but they're clinging to the
hope Britain's exit from the EU could
provide the opportunity to forge a new
life without having to hide in the
shadows for decades like many of their
predecessors have been forced to do Lisa
Holland Sky News